what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to alexander grace guy
realizes the truth about his muscles
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell while you're at it go follow me on
instagram i take all my video requests
on instagram this was submitted by one
of my subscribers
um and it's gonna be interesting guys
realizes
realizes the truth about his muscles and
i think the thumbnail says she wants to
feel small i'm six foot so
it'll be interesting for my pov okay
hey guys welcome back to the channel
today i want to read a post from the red
pill subreddit that i really enjoyed
it's called she wants to feel small
i remember something my ex-long-term
relationship said to me once while we
were [ __ ] i love it when you curl me
up into a ball i feel so small
a few months later i met up with a plate
that i hadn't seen in a while i had been
lifting properly for a couple of years
and i'm much bigger than i was when we
first hooked up she commented on it with
a large grin
wow you're so big now what happened
while rubbing my arms
what happened
five three one and 3 300 kcal a day
that's what happened
the next plate was bitching about her
boyfriend while laying on my plate for
anyone that doesn't know that's like a
girl that you hook up with
but don't date so it's like you're
spinning plates you're spinning girls
he was the same height as her and she
didn't like it she told me i love how
little i feel when i'm with you i love
it when you pick me up during wait it
was bitching about her boyfriend
what
that just went over my head for a second
what i thought about this for a while
and came to a few realizations a huge
part of the attraction these girls have
for men is the physical dominance in
order to get the tingles for a guy she
needs to feel the dude is much bigger
and stronger than her
i've had a lot of problems with tall
women and athletes in the past i can't
seem to hook up with tall girls even
though i have size and wit and frame i'm
still just too short for them to get
subconsciously aroused it seems this is
a common trope amongst all tall women
they are very picky because they are
still subject to the same psychological
forces all women are
that is she is only interested in guys
noticeably bigger than her which can be
hard if you're a six foot one girl oh my
god i'm six foot okay
i will say this isn't always the case i
know a lot of short guys that will tell
me stories that they pull tall girls and
that it's not a factor
um
i
for example the guy went to the pickup
event with
he told me that he has better luck with
taller girls um so i'm not saying this
is always the case
but
personally i'll take height over
anything i'll take hideover muscles like
i don't care if the guy is
super muscular
um
but
height
is really hard for me to get past and i
really wish it wasn't because i'm six
foot so
it makes dating a lot harder like if i
was five a five foot girl
i would 100 date a guy like five five
but when you're six foot like
it is really hard to be attracted to a
guy that's shorter than you
i'm not saying it doesn't happen um
especially a lot shorter like i'm six
foot so like five tennis is you know
fine but i'm always gonna prefer taller
sadly
i wish it wasn't the case it's just like
how it is i don't know
there was a girl i was running solid
game on once who lifted pretty well and
she treated me like dirt i just wasn't
big enough for her that was the reason
and it overshadowed everything else
when i saw her with the guy eventually
well this guy was a real [ __ ] beast
of a man an absolute unit she was like a
giddy school girl with him
he was a bit of a dweeb very blue but i
realized it didn't matter to her she
just wanted to feel small and feminine
and young around him
you'll have a hard time gaming women if
you're smaller than them and i don't
mean just height wise you can be taller
but if your stick thin if you look weak
she'll clock onto this and her [ __ ]
will be dry
i kind of
i don't mind a skinny guy i don't i mean
obviously like a twig
okay you have to understand there's the
ideal and like understanding that you
know guys are still human so it's not
my body's not perfect i don't expect
like a guy to be perfect
um
but yeah i don't stick thin isn't that
big of a deal to me height
you're better off being fat than skinny
for women at least fat mimics size and
hints at strength which is enough for
her you can get away with being shorter
or her height sometimes but only if you
have muscles to make up for it an
absolutely solid frame there's no way
around it you need to make her feel weak
she needs to feel like you can overpower
her at any moment for there to be any
way of her being attracted to you
if she feels like she can hold you off
in a fight or if she can stop you from
just taking her it's not possible she
can be attracted to you
it might sound i think being heavy
skinny i think all of the i think most
girls agree on height
but i think there's a lot of nuance
between girls that prefer big guys
skinny guys
um and just all of that stuff there's a
lot of you know gray area because it
kind of is women are [ __ ] up after all
damn
one of my plates loved it when i pinned
her wrist down during sex and would
struggle to break free
i allowed her not wanting any of that
hashtag me too nonsense then she would
get mad and call me weak a [ __ ]
i had to show her that i was actually
holding back a lot and that she could
never break free from me even when i was
putting in minuscule effort never felt
her come so i feel uncomfortable i feel
uncomfortable
women yearn to be small and smooth and
weak and feminine just as much as we
want to be big and rough and strong and
masculine it turns them on in irrational
subconscious ways are you able to make
her feel feminine are you able to make
her feel small
i've only ever been with one girl that
was my height and honestly it felt weird
it made me uncomfortable i'm so used to
girls being small and cute and inferior
around me that having a girl that felt
like my equal in stature left a bad
feeling in my stomach you know that's
odd
i
in college i think short guys approached
me more than anything like guys that are
around five five i i don't i can't tell
you why they love the six foot and up
all my friends in college were tall for
the most part like my short friends were
five five and that's you know average
height for a girl and they were short to
me
but
yeah
like i had less control like i was less
masculine
honestly i think she felt it too and
very much wished i was taller
the only way i managed to get away with
it was that there was an age difference
between us and she knew i was smarter
and more mature so this made her feel
inferior in other ways
because that's another important aspect
one that underlies all this small tall
talk she doesn't just want to feel small
around you she wants to feel inferior in
every way
she wants to be a small dumb little girl
in your eyes a little pet owned by a
capable collected and powerful man
trying to think what i try to be
open-minded right and sometimes y'all
sound crazy i'm not even gonna lie to
you like i'll hear you guys say things
i'm like a pet i don't want to be a pet
what are you talking about i don't know
when
i try to think guys i've dated
um i didn't think they were like a lot
smarter than me maybe
socially like i'm kind of awkward
they're probably socially
more charismatic than me maybe
if she feels like you're equals or even
worse if she feels like she's better
than you in any way stronger more
intelligent more socially adept more
emotionally adjusted you're going to
have a lot of problems with her at heart
she needs you to be better than her in
every way no exceptions all women i
think there's a lot of exceptions
because
there's a lot of middle ground that's
what the red pill gets wrong a lot there
is a ton of middle ground i know a girl
that's married
to a guy that makes less than her for
like 20 plus years fundamentally want to
feel inferior to their man they want and
i cringe saying this because i hate the
term to feel like a little girl with a
daddy owning her even if she can't
verbalize it
once you've lost the dad role and she no
longer feels like your innocent dumb
little play thing well she can't bring
herself to [ __ ] you anymore she wants to
be owned and dominated physically and
mentally
are you taller than her are you stronger
than her are you smarter more in tune
with the real world are you able to hold
your own in physical or verbal
confrontation she needs this from you
you can't avoid it
heck are you even able to pick her up i
don't know about you guys but i
absolutely loved this post there's a lot
that i want to discuss here so i'll just
take a short break and then we'll get
into the analysis okay well there's so
much good stuff to talk about here i
think that the most interesting part is
examining the psychology of why women
enjoy feeling inferior to men so i'll
save that for the end we'll start by
discussing some of the minor points i
agree with this post and i think that
it's absolutely accurate to say that
women enjoy being with a man who they
perceive to be superior to them well
there's some aspects i do think it's
superior to them in some way i don't
think it's every way
i mean maybe if you're like a model and
you think you can get a guy that's
better than you in every way
sure but i think so
i think most girls are somewhat
realistic
like we're not perfect effects of the
post that i would probably uh tweak or
change i know the manosphere is going to
disagree they're gonna be like no
women are so crazy
they have these high standards
like okay
i know a lot of normal women that have
normal standards it's not
it's not my fault you can't get them
like a little bit on the whole i agree
with its general message now when it
comes to the law men and women
absolutely should be treated equally
obviously that's a good thing because we
don't want a society with men's rights
and women's rights we want a society
with human rights but in all of this
discussion about equality we've
overlooked a basic truth because it's a
bit uncomfortable to mention that is
that while a woman wants respect and
equality in the workplace you know she
doesn't want to be discriminated against
because of her gender she doesn't really
want equality in her relationship she
wants to be with a man who she perceives
to be superior to her that's who she
finds sexually attractive she might feel
sorry for the timid and kind nice guy
who treats her like a goddess and with
the utmost respect that's not the person
that's going to make her sexually
aroused you're probably all familiar
with stories about hardcore feminist
girls who scream and rage about equality
who then happily go into the bedroom
with some guy who treats her really
rough and she loves it i have a buddy
who briefly dated one of these girls she
was a hardcore feminist really into all
of the activism and that stuff and he
would tease her mercilessly about it and
she would love it in the bedroom i think
girls really like banter if you're a guy
and you want game get good at banter
yeah we love a guy that can give us a
little [ __ ] she was crazy submissive
would let him do whatever he wanted i
actually asked this question to women in
one of my earlier interviews the one on
submission in relationships i asked them
would you like to be in a relationship
of equals or be with a man who you
perceive to be better than yourself
about half of the girls said that they
would want to be in a relationship of
equals
this sucks to say but don't believe them
i don't believe that true i think that
this is one of those areas where most
women are cognitively dissonant from
what they really want they say what they
think is the most politically correct
thing to say without taking the time to
examine their deepest feelings or look
at their past actions often they're not
even lying when they say this they're
just not aware of what motivates them at
the deepest level of their being i think
that it's funny how this particular
realization came to the author of this
post that women enjoy being with a man
who's superior to them because he saw it
play out in the most straightforward way
possible he was just physically larger
he is absolutely correct when he says
that women aren't going to be attracted
to a man who's smaller or skinnier than
they are and he's also correct when he
says that women want you to be superior
to them in as many different ways as
possible when i was in that's a better
way to put it as many ways as possible
i think girls are somewhat realistic
you have to remember
i want to say 80 percent of women get
married i think
i wonder what percent of women get
married i actually don't know but i want
to say it's the majority so they have to
pick someone at some point and they
can't all pick the top
20
of guys do some girls feel like they
settled i'm sure i'm sure that happens
but
just my two cents ali i was on the beach
watching the sunset and i struck up a
conversation with a girl she was a
ukrainian girl who worked in france as a
cabaret dancer she was 23 and extremely
beautiful when she told me that she had
a boyfriend i told her that i was going
to make some basic predictions about her
boyfriend i predicted that he was going
to be older than her i predicted that he
was going to be taller than her and i
also predicted that he was going to make
more money than her okay let me think my
last boyfriend
older no
taller yes
makes more money
yes
i was correct on all three counts i knew
that my predictions would be correct
because this girl was absolutely
stunning and with such a high sexual
market value she wouldn't settle for
anything less than a man who is superior
to her now let me make a confession here
i'm not a big gym guy i like playing
sport but whenever i've gone to the gym
and just done lifting weights i found
the whole thing extremely boring i know
that's not great and please don't take
my example as any kind of advice to how
to live your life you absolutely should
be going to the gym so you know do as i
say not as i do now in my life i've
noticed that not having big muscles
instantly disqualifies me as a sexual
prospect for some women i can see it as
i'm speaking to them we might be having
a great time getting along really well
very intellectually stimulating
conversation but there's no part of them
that's feeling sexually attracted to me
because at a base level they're just not
feeling that superiority i'm like the
guy in the post when it comes to really
well-built women or women who are taller
than me i just disqualified them as a
potential sexual prospect
i might really enjoy their company and
they might be a really good friend but
there's no real attraction there it's a
good rule of thumb for me the muscles
thing isn't i when i was in
i prefer
a skinnier guy to be honest over a big
muscular guy i never was into
super big muscles i don't know if it's
because maybe like
like it's like a subconscious thing like
i don't think i can get them or
something but
i remember in college i
like the basketball player that was like
my type
like tall skinnier lanky almost yeah at
a base level so what do you do if you're
a guy like me who either through
genetics or just basic laziness is never
going to be built like the rock well the
important thing is to make yourself
superior in other ways rather than just
the physical for me it's about
intelligence wisdom self growth things
like that i've always done extremely
well with girls who are sapiosexual for
other guys it might oh my god
sapiosexual
i'm not even gonna this is a very honest
reaction
when i hear a guy say sapiosexual i i
immediately think
like something's wrong with him because
that's such a stupid word like you're
attracted to intelligence
what do you mean
like
we all are to some level like we don't
want to date an idiot even guys i know
that's not a main thing for them
but those guys don't want to date a girl
that's as dumb as a doornail
like
that can that have the option right
be about how much money they make uh how
socially calibrated they are how much
status they enjoy
obviously the more of these boxes that
you can tick the better you don't have
to be the absolute best at something but
so long as you're superior to her she
will find that attractive even if you're
not a super crazy macho dude with lots
of muscles i still think that it's
important that physically you're
stronger than the woman that you're
dating so for me i'm not going to feel
particularly masculine if i'm hanging
around a bunch of professional athletes
or cage fighters but i still enjoy that
feeling of masculinity that's why i've
always enjoyed dating girls who are sort
of small and dainty and cute because by
comparison i'm extremely masculine and
it's a really enjoyable experience to
feel masculine around a woman i've
always suspected that this is the reason
why small nerdy kind of guys tend to
attract asian girlfriends because asian
culture promotes that kind of submissive
feminine kindness in their women and so
these guys still get to have their
experience of masculinity in that
relationship women enjoy watching men be
masculine they revel in it it's like the
author of this post said women
absolutely loved it when he was able to
pick them up
yeah okay yeah i can see that because it
made her feel small and in the arms of
someone who is big and strong when he
was being gentle with one of his lovers
in the sexually ah
i don't like talking about that stuff i
feel uncomfortable
like at all
she accused him of being weak and
actually called him a [ __ ] i mean
think about that that's crazy but at
that moment she's not in politically
correct brain mode she's in raw animal
instinct sexual mode for those of you
who have studied pickup artist stuff
you're probably familiar with the term
neck oh my gosh i think nag is just
another word for banter
they're like girls like to be insulted
it's banter i love a good banter
i'm kind of mean to the guys i like
sometimes
it's bad i'm not good at flirting like
girls could should not take advice from
me because when i flirt like
i kind of bully you a little bit i'm not
even gonna lie i do
it's a problem it's an issue okay
because a good banter i don't know it's
fun
i do it with girls too you know it's a
form of flirtation where you subtly sort
of insult the girl you say something
like oh wow you wear a lot of makeup
don't you or oh okay i wasn't talking
about that i don't like that
i've never had a guy do something like
that to me to me and nag maybe i got the
definition wrong and nag is more
um
god i can't think of a good
a good one off the top of my head
it's it's more just like banter you know
like okay for example like i could beat
you in one-on-one and i kind of like
look at your ass trash like that that's
the kind of banter i'm in i could never
date you you're too weird something like
that when these guys are trying to pick
see that's a good one i couldn't do the
you wear a lot of makeup because one i
don't but if a guy said you need to wear
makeup i would not appreciate that
but
i guess it's all on how you say it
though because it has to be it has to be
clear that you're kidding but and it's
like a sarcasm thing
that she can like come back at you with
yeah pick up really high quality girls
the next can get quite intense i've seen
videos online of guys openly calling
women [ __ ] and [ __ ] telling them that
they're ugly and women absolutely loving
it why is this what's going on you just
see that video for a really blue pill
guy this doesn't make any sense at all
why would a woman respond positively to
such a mean comment it's because of the
reasons that are spoken about in this
post if a man is confident enough to
speak down to a woman like that it
demonstrates that he is superior to her
which she finds attractive of course
there's no need to be insulting to women
in order to demonstrate superiority but
there's no denying that it works
it does require very very solid social
calibration yeah that's what i'm saying
you have to do it right because oh my
gosh if you don't if you do it wrong
but once you've practiced and you've got
it down
it can be used to achieve very quick
results now i don't agree with the
author when he says that women are
[ __ ] up to me that's an intellectual
cop-out it's oversimplifying a situation
because you don't want to put the work
in to actually discover the
psychological causes of behavior and
motivation when you stop and think about
it you realize that there is a reason
why women respond positively to negative
comments it might look [ __ ] up on the
surface but there is a certain logic a
certain rationale behind it that's what
i want to talk about next the psychology
of why women want to be with a man who
they perceive to be superior to
themselves i'll take a short break and
then we'll get into it so why do why do
you tell me if you're gonna make take a
break sir you could just edit it out
i don't care
women want to be with a man who they
perceive to be superior to themselves
the short answer is they want to feel
safe for those of you who are familiar
with the works of jordan peterson you
will have heard him speak about the yin
yang symbol of taoism you've got the yin
of chaos and the yang of order now we
tend to associate chaos with the
feminine
and order with the masculine when a
woman wants a strong confident man who's
superior to her she wants him to protect
her from the chaos of the outside world
and the chaos that's inside her to be
with a man who is the chaos that's
inside me what does that mean
what does that mean
financially wealthy and extremely
intelligent
makes a woman feel safe because she
feels confident in his ability to handle
whatever chaos the world throws at him
he's physically strong enough to beat up
aggressors and defend her against people
who would attack her he makes enough
money to protect her from homelessness
and starvation and he's intelligent
enough to see through the tricks and
manipulations of anyone who might try
and take advantage of her at a core
level women understand that it's men's
biological role to protect women and so
when a superior man comes along she
responds sexually
if she feels herself to be more capable
than the man she's interacting with she
might really like him but a huge part of
her brain will be thinking well what do
i need him for she will never respond to
that man sexually but this part is quite
obvious most people understand that
women want to be with superior man to
protect them from the dangers of the
outside world
what's less obvious is how women want
men to protect them from the dangers
inside themselves deep down beneath all
of the politeness and civility of modern
society there lies a destructive and
chaotic force that will destroy
everything it comes in contact with what
the this is the dark feminine
women are aware of its existence they
can feel it deep down inside themselves
okay they live in fear that this
destructive and irrational force will
burst forth from within them and destroy
everything that it touches
i'm not even gonna alexander if you see
this
i do not feel that way i i don't know
why
but
i
the dark feminine what are you guys
talking about that's why it makes women
feel so safe when a man calls them out
on their [ __ ] they might try some no
no no we feel safe because we feel human
there's so many guys that don't treat us
like we're human
so oh my god
i
oh my god
i i went on a couple dates with this guy
and he wanted to date me so fast and i
actually i agree with rolos tomasi's
rule i don't know if i agree with it
completely like roland tamasu's role of
like don't be the first to ask for a
commitment
sorry um
i don't want to say never because
sometimes it's just easier to like have
that conversation and be honest and up
front
but there's no other way to kill your
value than to just
like want to be official so quick and
just
be so
like pushing the like the commitment and
stuff on
oh my god because i was like
we gotta
slow down
lies some manipulations some deceptions
but if their partner sees clearly what
they're doing and says firmly stop it
cut that out it makes them feel relieved
for the first time they don't need to be
so vigilant in keeping their chaos from
erupting forth because they have a
strong male partner who they trust will
keep them in line this is why men who
never stand up to their female partners
who let them do and say yeah
that's the biggest mistake you can make
do not be afraid to stand up to your
girlfriend or wife
now look at it i
i i think you know sometimes you have to
be able to compromise and like
me in the middle you know i think the
manosphere is against that maybe but i
think there's a lot of middle ground
that
like general rules don't
cover
but
yeah
if you just worship the ground she walks
on
fellas
it's not cute it's really not
we want to feel like we earned you we
want to feel like we deserve you no
matter how destructive eventually become
repulsive to women it's like they're
screaming out can't you see i'm being an
irrational [ __ ] right now i'm [ __ ]
crazy and i'm so mad at you for not
calling me out on it a real man wouldn't
let me act like such a spoiled entitled
princess this is the psychology behind
some [ __ ] tests when women say something
rude or insulting it's a huge relief to
them to see that it hasn't upset their
partner that their chaos has had no
impact on his order
that kind of strength and masculinity
can inspire intense sexual attraction
when the author says that women want
their partner to be their daddy this is
what he's referring to a strong
authoritative father figure who has
clear boundaries and lays down the law
when it comes to what is yeah and is not
i agree with that that's true that's
very true acceptable behavior men and
women are different
while men are motivated to find as much
freedom as possible women are motivated
to find safety
i don't
i'm not a fan of controlling guys though
i don't know if that's what he's
implying but
oh my gosh
i can't
i can't do controlling i think my dad
has always told me that people don't
like to be controlled and to give people
the freedom to do what they want
now i'm not saying it's hard because
there is a fine line and i think
you know
my dad's lucky where my mom's like
level-headed enough to not you know like
cheat on my dad or like like do anything
crazy you know but
i don't know my parents always just let
us do whatever the hell we wanted pretty
much and we all turned out okay like all
my siblings make six figures except me
drop a donation in the chat drop a
donation
help me get there help me not be the
family disappointment anymore please i'm
just playing they don't want to run wild
and do whatever they want that kind of
unrestrained freedom scares them deep
down a lot of women know that they can
be completely irrational even total
[ __ ] that's why this especially the
week before your girl but the week
before your girls period
it's not you man she's crazy
the week before pleasure when it comes
to things like dominant and submissive
sexual play he might be spanking her
whipping her insulting her doing any
number of things and she's absolutely
loving it because in her mind she's
thinking that chaotic part of me that's
visible to him he sees that he's
responding to it he's keeping it in line
thank god that he knows that this
chaotic part of me exists therefore he
won't let it get out of control if a man
is treating a woman as if she's some
kind of perfect angel who can do no
wrong it's not going to make her feel
safe
in her mind she's going to be thinking
he doesn't see this chaotic destructive
force that lies
[Music]
i would say he doesn't
he doesn't treat me human but yeah okay
you know fair enough
and so he's not going to be ordered or
masculine enough to make sure that that
chaos is kept under control i don't
trust him and i certainly don't feel
safe around him ultimately the lesson is
improve yourself
if you become the superior man all
aspects of your life will improve and
you'll improve the lives of all the
women that's true that's very good
advice come into contact too
women will find you intensely sexually
attractive if you want to see the deeper
side of a woman both emotionally and
sexually then you need to make her feel
safe that's a good thing about being a
guy okay because all right facially
right
i give myself like a five i think if i
lost 20 pounds i could be a six now i
don't this is not permission to correct
me in the comments and give me a lower
rating keep that to yourself
anyways
so
body wise right we can improve but girls
facially if you get a messed up face you
really can't fix that unless you pay for
surgery whatever but
i think there's only so much surgery you
can do personal opinion as a guy if you
become rich as [ __ ]
yeah then then you'll have your pick of
the litter to be honest go out and
become the kind of guy who makes women
feel safe
improve yourself become superior embrace
unless you're short
just kidding if you're rich and short
girls will still want you but
that's i'm not even gonna lie that's
that's a tough hurdle like if a guy is
5'2 oh no i'm sorry you just weren't
lucky your masculinity and then you can
enjoy your increased level of sexual
attractiveness before we finish up i
think it's important to mention that for
the sake of brevity i've been speaking
in generalizations in this video blah
blah blah that's that's i don't even
understand why do we as content creators
oh no have i been behind
i'm sorry if i've been behind that but
we as content creators should not have
to say that
we we do when we do do it but like
are you guys not smart enough to know
that clearly these are general rules and
not specifics to every situation duh
duh so
sorry
i get heated okay guys um let me know if
you guys like this reaction don't forget
to subscribe to the channel please poor
favorite
please okay
and i will talk to you guys next time